bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france tout d'abord une
question sur les familles des victimes
dans ce contexte particulier comment se
porte-t-elle on sait que le procès a été
suspendu dans quel état d'esprit sont l
écouter les familles les victimes les
survivants sont en dedans effectivement
une situation à la fois d'attentes de
d'interrogation il faut pas oublier
l'environnement que la france a connu
depuis l'ouverture de ce procès et
depuis quelques mois
et tous ces événements tous ces
attentats toutes ces menaces font que
ces victimes sont encore plus
vulnérables
rappelant que les traumatismes ses
blessures ces douleurs n'ont pas pu se
cicatriser encore pour ce qui est des
attentats dans le le procès cinq longues
années après ne s'est pas encore tenu
donc c'est une situation d'attenté avec
une fragilité et avec un lourd
traumatisme et de nour de douleur et de
lourdes ses caprices
on imagine justement une douleur des
cicatrices qui se rouvrent quand on
annonce d'autres attentats en france
comment le vivent ted cela doit être
extrêmement compliqué pour l écouter
très très mal très mal je peux vous dire
que j'ai des certaines victimes que je
suis depuis 5e année certaines se
trouvent mal j'ai même une une victime
un client qui a dû être hospitalisé
d'urgence tant le traumatisme est le
l'attentât notamment pour parler de
cette victime il s'agit du vigile dam
des vigiles du stade de france que je
suis qui a dû être internée
du fait de ce show qui du fait de tout
ce que ça pu impacter c'est que ces
attentats ont pu intenter enfin refaire
vivre chez lui comme douleur comment
s'expliquent tels ces victimes ces
attaques cette alerte terroriste très
élevé en france est-ce qu'elles ont
veulent au gouvernement est ce qu'elle
s'envole l'idéologie ces islamistes quel
est leur état d'esprit là dessus écoutez
ces victimes sont d'abord dans une
situation de 2,2 triste et ce2
d'attentes latente d'une vérité la tente
de savoir comment comment ils ont pu
perdre leurs proches leur office le rhum
leurs frères leurs maris donc c'est pas
ton de la colère que la tante de nom
d'une vérité la tante d'une explication
comme en a tant fait pour ne pas éviter
de ne pas avoir évité ce ce drame et cet
attentat donc la colère et les biens sur
un second plan mais le premier plan
c'est comment leur chair leur onze ans
reproche ont-ils pu connaître la vie ils
ont ils sont dans la tente de n'importe
quel détail qui a était à l'occasion de
cette mort terrible ont-ils souffert
avant de mourir ont-ils dit à moussa v
ils sont à la recherche de du moindre
détail pour comprendre les circonstances
de la mort de leurs proches
on a vu récemment ces images en jet
privé des terroristes denis sera menée
pour être soigné peut-être à paris où ça
a choqué vous c'est quoi votre regard
d'avocate il fallait le ramener dans ces
conditions pour le soigner pour
peut-être justement avoir un procès de
façon à ce que les victimes puissent
comprendre ce qui s'est passé c'est ce
genre de buts que l'on poursuit quand on
arrête un terroriste
vous savez les familles de victimes
permettez-moi de le dire haut et fort ne
sont ni dans une situation ni un état
d'esprit de vengeance ou de revanche
ils sont dans une attente de la vérité
savait quand on a perdu ce qu'on a de
plus cher
on n'est pas dans des ddd un
questionnement de comment et dans
quelles conditions dans quelles
circonstances
ramener un terroriste ou lefebvre
rapatriés nous sommes voyez vous madame
la différence entre notre état de droit
et la l'état de 2 d'endoctrinement et de
et d'anarchie situation à laquelle ces
terroristes veulent arriver
et bien moi en tout cas de ce que je
vois de des clients que je suis des
victimes du terrorisme que je suis ils
sont dans la tente de voir les
responsables quel que soit le niveau de
leurs responsabilités que ça soit ce
plan financier ce qui en a armé
ceux qui ont logé ceux qui ont loué des
voitures se cliente endoctrinés saut ce
qui est à l'origine de l'armement de ces
personnes il faut savoir il faut les
arrêter
il faut qu'il réponde il faut qu'il
réponde à la justice c'est ça les
tableaux de mai pour en revenir
justement aux attentats d'il ya cinq ans
une figure importante s'adapter sam va
comparaître en janvier 2021 est ce que
ces familles attendent beaucoup de
réponses de lui on sait qu'il n'a pas du
tout voulu parler
les avocats lorsqu'il était incarcéré
est ce qu'on peut en attendre beaucoup
est ce qu'il n'ya pas peut-être de la
frustration et de la déception à la clé
écoutez laissez moi vous dire qu'une
instruction a été menée pendant cinq
longues années des magistrats
instructeurs français omlt manier et en
instruit de manière remarquable les
attentats pour permettre à la vérité
d'éclater
aujourd'hui l'instruction qui vient
d'être clôturée a été menée sans
l'intervention de du terroriste salade
de slam c'est grâce à l'instruction
grâce à à tous tout le travail qui a été
fait par le pôle antiterroriste de paris
que cette instruction a été menée à bien
et achevés à temps
est ce que nous sommes en situation
d'attendre quelque chose de sale arabe
dit cela je pense que là la preuve nous
a été apportée sur sa stratégie de
défense qui est celle du mutisme de ces
noeuds de ne pas coopérer
malgré ses promesses mais qu'attend que
peut-on attendre d'un terroriste il est
dans le mensonge
il est dans la manipulation dans la
taqiyya aujourd'hui mais les victimes
sont pas celles que je représente
attendent beaucoup de l'instruction
qualité mené des moyens gigantesques qui
ont été mis à la disposition du pôle
antiterroriste russe pour que la vérité
éclate et que pour la condamnation soit
à la hauteur de ce que ses victimes en
dut en deux ans d'ulcérer et vivre
pendant ces cinq longues années et qu'il
continue évidemment aaa à endurer cela
ma dernière question il ya l'aspect donc
judiciaire dont on vient de parler
l'aspect aussi politique avait un mini
sommet hier consacrée à la lutte contre
le terrorisme à l'échelle européenne on
appelle toujours voilà l'unification etc
on se demande toujours pourquoi les
choses n'ont pas été faites avant vous
attendez vous beaucoup en tant
qu'avocate spécialisée dans
terrorisme de ce type de sommet on va
assez vite selon vont écouter c'est
important qu'ils des sommets parce que
je crois qu on a mis beaucoup de temps
avant de comprendre que le terrorisme ne
peut pas être menée par un seul état le
terrorisme poursuivi par ses théories
c'est un terrorisme planétaire et si les
états ne se ne sut ne met pas la main
dans la main pour lutter contre ce
terrorisme on n'y arrivera pas sachant
que le risque zéro n'existe pas et que
plus on on s'unit pour échanger des
renseignements pour coopérer en matière
de renseignement au niveau européen et
au delà même de l'europe
c'est ainsi qu'on pourra efficacement
lutter contre le terrorisme
oui j'espère que ce mini sommet
permettra ne serait-ce que les changes
et la coopération entre les différents
états l' échange d informations
concernant les terroristes concernant
toutes les personnes radicaliser non
encore passés à une action des personnes
fichées des personnes qui ne sont pas
dans les radars des renseignements des
mini sommet comme ça pourrait beaucoup
apporter
merci sam hier avec tours avocate de
familles de victimes du 13 novembre
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france perd c'est bon